allez on va jouer avec quelques chiffres
sur rudy gobert qui rit joue avec nous
également on joue au plus haut - je vous
donne des chiffres sur rudy et vous
jouez également chez vous à vous de me
dire si c'est plus souscrire mois
lorsqu'il avait 15 ans rudy musée mesure
est il plus ou moins d'un mètre 90 bon
évidemment quand il avait 15 ans plus ou
moins d'un mètre quatre-vingt-dix
évident alors attendez parce qu'il ya
des objets déco qui essayait de
comprendre le jeu donc plus il ya tout
le monde dit plus sauf qu'elle y tue
mesurer combien cas à 15h et et kiri en
mai 93
et ouais un mètre 93 à 15 ans est restée
plus à 15 ans par exemple en compte ou
pas bah ça la magie c'est la liberté
qu'on en dit après on stagne après il
n'a pas constaté de centimètres ce qui
peut se taper les avoir pris 6,3 cm tu
mesures qu'on a maintenant ruddy buquet
2 15 mai de 17 de 17 ch te rajoute 2
centimes à 3,4 avec le gamin merde pour
que passe partout soit aussi gros que
rudy gobert doit-il monter sur un
escabeau de plus ou moins d'un mètre à
la plus abîmée revers de 7-2 mais bien
non c'est moi non pas par tout est bien
plus grand que vous le pensez il mesure
1 m 20 donc pour être à la même taille
que rudy du monde 96 cm on embrasse
d'aidé bientôt midi show style plus ou
moins que du 52 mono de chez moi alors
je vous le dis petit indice
il ne trouve pas sa taille chez sarenza
je voudrais dire ici alors plus ou moins
seulement de kawa tu penses plus aussi
chose du combien sa pause 3-0 alors
comment tu fais mon frère c'est clair
parce que quand tu arrives moi j'arrête
quand arrive chez bata voilà pourquoi
une battue va même pas les mêmes pour ta
bille et tout fait comme en bas sur
mesure souvent tout sur mesure c'est que
je suis un bon couturier tu peux te
faire des trois trucs non mais c'est
vrai quoi t'es obligé tu peux pas d'être
un magasin tata billets bah je perds pas
mon temps
ouais ça veut dire que rigoberte si un
jour vous l'appelez vous dit non je vais
faire du shopping aujourd'hui tu sais
que c'est un mytho jamais de shopping
marie ici ouf
oui même les slips comme l'estiment sur
mesure c'est pas une si mauvaise
émission sur mesure
tu peux ah ouais quand même ah bon
[Applaudissements]
rappelle qu'on parlera on parlera bull
tout à l'heure avec la fin
oui je voulais savoir comment tu faisais
pour les basques les baskets à la mode
des jeunes c'est rudy gobert il avalé un
contrat c'est oui et tout est à refaire
je suis d'accord oui à la bonne taille
et lui c'est au basket c'est ce que
soulève ce que benjamin castadi à
l'ophtalmologie des chiots paix
on a également le blé bras tendus vers
le ciel rudy arrive-t-il à plus ou moins
de trois mètres du sol
ah non non non non
alors il n'a pas les bras la mettre en
moins alors non non c'est moi c'est
presque 1,2 mètre 92 tend les bras vers
le ciel il fait 2 mètre 92 le panier à
combien le panier la 3 mètres commun
vous l'avez trouvé où cette photo c'est
celle-là ça je comprends les photos les
moins chers c'est quoi cette photo où
cette photo c'est vrai il ya combien le
panneau 3 053 05 c'est ça ouais ouais
l'envergure d'un aigle royal est elle
plus ou moins grande que celle de rudy
l'envergure d'un aigle royal annonce
envoyée en moi j'en ai un j'en ai un qui
a dormi deux semaines à la maison ça
prend de la place dans le lit plus ou
moins mais et l'aigle royal
isabelle coûts qui connaissait des
animaux alors l'aigle royal et c'est
vrai que c'est dire est plus un tout
petit peu plus mais je peux me tromper
non les locaux sauvage le faucon sauvage
non le comptage est plus grosses
couilles le faucon mais ce que le vrai
composteur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est pas vrai pas un petit peu moins
rapidement parce que l aigle royal a une
envergure maximale de 2 mètres 30 et
redit deux mètres 36 salariés un aigle
royal qui lui met un coup de pression
c'est comme ça j'ai préféré partir avec
mon frère trop content ou pas c'est un
aigle royal qui veut s'embrouiller avec
rudy parce que ça arrive des agro rial
qui veulent sont brouillées aujourd'hui
à paris un rudy tu lui mets un coup de
pression il s'en va direct bien j'en
croise à lui pas souvent sont en
croissance